bonjour merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette nouvelle édition de votre journal
du vendredi nous sommes le 22 janvier et
voici les titres première cérémonie de
voeux pour le président de la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines c'était jeudi soir au vélodrome
à montigny le bretonneux
nous ferons le point sur les principales
annonces comme chaque fin de semaine
nous revenons aussi sur l'essentiel de
l'actualité depuis lundi du premier
conseil régional d'ile-de-france présidé
par valérie pécresse aux inquiétudes du
département sur les finances en passant
par le pop art cours du fc mantois en
coupe de france de football et puis
enfants d'édition retour sur la
disparition de l'écrivain michel
tournier nous vous proposons de
découvrir l'entretien qu'il nous avait
accordé en 2001 dans son presbytère de
choisel dans les yvelines commune où se
dérouleront ces funérailles lundi le
département des yvelines vient de se
pencher ce vendredi matin sur son budget
pour 2016 un budget compliqué entre
hausse des dépenses sociales mais
surtout baisse des dotations de l'état
il faudra donc augmenter les impôts
on retiendra entre autres côté dépenses
que 113 millions d'euros sont proposés
pour la politique des routes et des
transports et qu'une enveloppe de 190
millions d'euros est également proposée
pour les travaux dans les collèges
publics
ce sera pour la période 2010 est 2020
nous ferons un point complet dans notre
édition de lundi
hier jeudi le préfet des yvelines a de
son côté organisé sa première cérémonie
de voeux depuis son arrivée à ce poste
pendant l'été 2015
serge morvan tenait à rassembler les
acteurs locaux les politiques également
le président du sénat lors embolie temps
gérard larcher était présent a pas d'
intervention officielle au programme
mais un temps des changes après une
année à difficile vous voyez les
différents maires des communes de saint
quentin qui était présent et serge mans
vent en aparté s'est néanmoins réjoui de
la diminution de la délinquance dans le
département entre 2014 et 2015 -8%
d'atteintes aux biens et un taux
d'élucidation qui progresse de 27%
les premiers éléments que nous avons
sur l'année 2015 semble effectivement
nous dire que l'évolution de la
délinquance dans les yvelines suis
plutôt une trajectoire positive et que
finalement de nombreux de nombreux items
comme l'on dit dans le jargon
diminue en 2015 par rapport à 2014
simplement effectivement c'est plutôt
positif dans l'ensemble pour les
yvelines en 2015
voilà ce que je peux dire à ce stade les
cérémonies de voeux se poursuivent à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines son président
tenait lui aussi sa première cérémonie
depuis le rapprochement avec plaisir
maurepas les clayes-sous-bois coignières
et villepreux
c'était au vélodrome à montigny le
bretonneux dans une grande affluence
le point sur les annonces avec ce sujet
les images sont signés patrick jacques
de dixmude 2016 sera une année pour aux
fines et l'organisation de la nouvelle
agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines compétences à définir mais
aussi rôle des nouveaux élus lors de sa
cérémonie de voeux au vélodrome à
montigny le bretonneux le président
michel laugier a néanmoins dévoilé
plusieurs réalisations bien concrète à
venir dans les prochains mois
sur le plan de l'habitat le
développement du quartier de villas roi
à guyancourt l'aménagement de la zac des
bécanes à la verrière le logement axes
de travail majeurs et de nouvelles
possibilités qui s'ouvrent avec
l'arrivée des nouvelles communes telles
que ville preuves sur le plan des
transports le réseau de bus existants
sera améliorée un service de voitures en
autopartage est en réflexion mais la
priorité reste le développement
économique est le message adressé aux
entreprises est clair on encore des
mètres carrés à pouvoir proposer et je
sais que dans cette cérémonie de voeux
beaucoup de promoteurs sont présents
donc s'ils sont présents c'est qu'ils
sont intéressés par d'autres territoires
lors de cette cérémonie une absence
remarquée celle de l'opposition le parti
socialiste qui a choisi de boycotter
l'événement le député blinois benoît
hamon annonce dans un communiqué dénoncé
ainsi l'absence des élus ps au sein de
l'exécutif du nouveau saint quentin
seuls maires de gauche
aperçue dans le public celui de la
verrière le communiste alain âge chacun
fait ce qu'il veut
moi j'invite tout le monde et j'ai fait
des voeux pour l'ensemble de
l'agglomération et j'ai bien fait voir
que j'étais le président de toutes les
communes de saint quentin en yvelines
après à chacun de savoir ce qu'il doit
faire politique toujours et le parti
socialiste des yvelines qui vient
d'interpeller à son premier secrétaire
national à travers une motion adoptée à
93% par ses adhérents elle les
sympathisants et militants du
département demande à ce dernier à 2
s'engager contre l'inscription de la
déchéance de la nationalité dans la
constitution un sujet et qui divise dans
les différentes formations politiques et
aussi à gauche
il ajoute ces militants et sympathisants
du département socialiste je cite ceux
qui n'ont que l'échéance présidentielle
de 2017 en tête ne devrait pas perdre de
vue que le soutien de ses sympathisants
sera pourtant indispensable pour se
qualifier au deuxième tour c'est donc un
avertissement qu'adresse les militants
au responsable département responsables
nationaux pardon vous retrouverez juste
après ce journal c'est fort en allemagne
pour le 7-8 week-end avec les idées
sorties et loisirs pour les prochains
jours et peut-être à assister vous ce
week end à une représentation de marche
ou rêve c'est à l'estaminet à magny les
hameaux mots musique acrobatie
scénographie s'associent pour raconter
la quête du petit team à la recherche et
des rêves de sa maman regarder
l'histoire du petit team à la recherche
des rêves de sa mère marche ou rêve un
conte circassiens et musical le thème la
marche comme masse corporelle est
imaginaire avant c'est aller au devant
du monde et des autres risques et le
déséquilibre au tour des parents les
parties marché tout simplement on a fait
tout un travail on est parti sur le
chemin de compostelle et puis sur
d'autres d'autres chemins et ce à partir
de cette matière là qu'on a commencé à
faire des recherches faire des
recherches autour du conte donc de
recherche autour des contes de la marche
et puis des comptes avec des quêtes et
des recherches aussi au niveau corporel
de voix de corée voulu un équilibre sur
une structure en bon bout et corps de
fileuse alliance d'une conteuse
chanteuse et d'une acrobate aérienne un
univers poétique signature de la
compagnie lunatic le langage de
prédilection de la compagnie c'est
l'acrobatie aérienne mais on crée des
spectacles mélanger ou
musique vivante la scénographie le
cirque le théâtre la danse
ce mail est on
on occupe l'espace très souvent avec des
spectacles en circulaire en seront on
aime bien confronter le rapport au
public dans les lieux différents
marche ou rêve un spectacle créé en 2012
qui sera en tournée dans toute la france
cette année prochaines dates dans les
yvelines
13 14 et 15 mars à rambouillet au pôle
culturel de la lanterne
et puisque nous parlons culture omar sy
était de retour à saint quentin en
yvelines hier soir le trappistes été est
venu à l'ugc pour présenter son nouveau
film chocolat montigny-le-bretonneux l
histoire du premier artiste noir de la
scène française c'est dans une france
coloniale antisémite xénophobe et qu'il
va connaître l'apogée de son succès
réalisations signées roschdy zem sur les
écrans à partir du 3 février
on passe à présent à l'essentiel de la
semaine ce qu'il faut retenir de
l'actualité locale depuis lundi le
zapping de l'info tout de suite et dans
l'actualité de ce mardi 19 janvier la
disparition à 91 ans de l'écrivain
michel tournier
il s'est éteint hier à son domicile un
ancien presbytère à choisel dans les
yvelines où il s'était installé en 1957
le département qu'il connaissait bien
pour avoir fait ses études au collège
sainte et robert de saint germain en
laye en 1941 il avait quitté la maison
familiale occupée par l'armée allemande
emploi transport sécurité à la veille de
sa première séance en tant que
présidente de la région ile de france
valérie pécresse a dévoilé ces mesures
prioritaires ce mercredi généralisation
de la vidéo protection dans les gares
aide au financement dans la réalisation
de nouvelles prisons ou encore création
du conseil stratégique pour
l'attractivité et l'emploi cela signifie
donc une hausse d'un pour faire un
exemple toujours dans les yvelines les
contribuables propriétaires vont devoir
payer 125 euros de plus sur leur taxe
foncière pierre bédier que vous voyez à
l'image le président du département des
yvelines et ses homologues de
seine-et-marne de l'essonne du val
d'oise se sont réunis au sein d'une
association grande couronne capitale et
ils viennent de donner une conférence de
presse presse commune avec un seul mot
d'ordre est dénoncée en les écoutant
waterloo sociale le petit robot filet
qui s'était posé sur la comète souris ne
donne plus signe de vie
la mission rosetta peut-être quand même
être qualifié de succès nous y
reviendrons avec cyril saux pas
chercheur à l'aube à ce qu invité c'est
de ce journal toutes les mesures qui ont
été faites à l'atterrissage de 12
novembre 2014 ont été ont été publiés
aujourd'hui dans des journaux
scientifiques et nous ont apporté des
informations très intéressantes
auxquelles on n'a pas accès depuis
l'orbité de la comète la galerie des
sablons situe à plaisir va subir un
lifting de grande ampleur le permis de
construire du nouveau centre commercial
open sky vient d'être signé l annonce a
été faite pendant la cérémonie de voeux
du maire de la commune joséphine commons
berger officiellement c'est à dire voir
qu'il ya des accidents voir comment tu
attrapes les et puis à l'issue de cette
période de des faits l'expérimentation
les pouvoirs publics défieront kiwi
voulons c'est bien fin de l'aventuré du
fc mantois 78 en coupe de france les
sang et or yvelinois qui évolue en cfa
se sont inclinés ce mercredi en 16e de
finale au stade aimé bergeal après
prolongation 1 0 contre le club de ligue
1 du fc nantes
je suis vraiment déçu comme je disais
précédemment c'est qu'on l'attendait
vraiment les tirs au but
on avait réussi à les emmener en
prolongation le but il est l objet qui
filent et a atteint après ça j'ai joué
70 minutes
donc voilà une erreur d'inattention
contre les
ligue 1 sept trappistes de 12 à 16 ans
seront élus du 19 au 22 janvier pour
renouveler le conseil municipal des
jeunes élus pour deux ans cette instance
créée en 2006 à trappes permet aux
jeunes d'organiser sorties culturelles
actions solidaires et citoyennes ainsi
que des voyages d'études en décembre une
nouvelle caméra a été installée près de
la gare en moyenne chaque année deux
caméras sont installées dans la commune
dont la politique de surveillance
remonte au début des années 2000 nous
avons refait il y a un an ou deux
maintenant notre centre de supervision
urbaine et puis bah nous rajoutons des
caméras et nous changeons aussi
certaines de caméras avec maintenant
tout ce qui se fait de mieux dans le
domaine technique au mois de mars 2015
l'école a décidé de partir pour le
campus paris saclay l'état est
propriétaire du lieu et des
investisseurs privés se montrent
intéressés pour l'investir dont le club
de football du paris saint germain
il pourrait installer son nouveau camp
de base à grignon avec entre autres un
stade de 5000 places et 18 terrains de
football le groupe français l'oréal est
lui aussi intéressé voilà pour
l'essentiel de la semaine ce sont à
présent les jeunes qui vont s'exprimer
sur l'actualité locale nationale comment
ont-ils perçu les derniers jours de
l'information séquence préparé par
mélanie poké cette semaine avec les
élèves du collège des saules à
guyancourt comme toujours le montage est
signée florent lamotte
ouais merci c'est un humoriste et acteur
fait rigoler les gens je ferai c'est un
bon exemple d'avoir choisi marc 6 passes
qui parce qu'elle est noire et y est
comme ça nous mûri ce débat ça lui va
bien parce que tout le monde même un
petit peu quand même et tout en barrant
canton l'aiment bien à mon avis un petit
peu je pense que dans les années 1900
c'était compliqué pour personne noire de
travailler comme ça bah oui péter parce
que des fois il ya des gens qui sont
racistes on voit de qui j'imagine que
par exemple au début quand et comme
première mort et stone a commencé tout
le monde l'a critiqué s'appelle pratique
déjà si on a besoin de faire les courses
d'urgence par exemple de dernier moment
ça peut toujours le dépanner on va dire
après ça c'est niveau employés je me
demande si ça fait pas un peu quand même
passer par un peu gênant plus dimanche
déjà c'est censé être le week end
donc si on travaille le samedi déjà on
compte sur le dimanche pour se reposer
mais sinon si on travaille toute une
semaine sans faire de pause je vois pas
vraiment comment on peut prendre le
temps de des fois après voilà quoi se
reposer passer du temps avec sa famille
à partir du moment où c'est la personne
qui propose on peut pas s'y opposer
c'est un abraham 11 ans mais vraiment si
ça devient obligé par exemple là ce
serait limite pas spécialement dans mon
entourage mais j'ai vu beaucoup de
beaucoup de personnes aux informations
qui ont parlé et notamment il y avait il
ya pas longtemps au scandale chez post
avec bricorama ou casse toi mais je sais
que c'était quoi ce qui était pourri dit
que ça servait beaucoup forcément
l'entreprise x a augmenté
le reçu mais ce qui était content et
surtout qu'ils écrasé la concurrence
déloyale qu'on n'avait pas le droit
parce que je crois qu'il ya des heurts
limités par semaine
paf avait trouvé un peu ce côté là qua
lité locale revient dès lundi en direct
à 18h sur notre antenne première
diffusion à 19 heures et aussitôt replay
sur le site tv fil 78 points comme avant
de poursuivre cette édition voici
quelques-uns des sujets sur lesquels
nous reviendrons justement la semaine
prochaine il sera question de cette
conférence organisée par le collectif
parole à coeur ouvert de trappes son
titre parlant de l'islam passé et
présent des représentations au fantasme
un islamologue anthropologue des
religions sera présent rendez vous
programmé lundi soir et puis tout autre
sujet rencontre à suivre aussi la
semaine prochaine avec xavier pincement
à 25 ans en second de cuisine au
restaurant gordon ramsay au trianon à
versailles
il est l'un des candidats de la nouvelle
saison de top chef programmée sur m6 un
mot du programme de radio sensations nos
confrères vous propose ce week end un
hebdo politique avec bertrand ou lyon le
maire socialiste de magny les hameaux il
évoque l'avenir de sa commune maison de
l'environnement géré handicap ou encore
élargissement de l'agglomération de 7 à
12 communes
écoutez cet extrait au cours duquel il
est question de la fermeture de la pmi
sur sa commune le centre de prévention
maternelle et infantile dernièrement
j'ai fait une relance parce que j'avais
quelques échos qui me revenaient qui des
rumeurs qui le disaient non non ça va
fermer
donc j'ai envoyé j'ai envoyé un courrier
j'ai enfin une réponse c'est la première
réponse conseil départemental depuis des
années sur quelque sujet que ce soit et
puis la réponse eh ben non on va fermer
selon l'april a fermé apparemment le
conseil départemental soit fermé la pmi
de magny les hameaux
vous avez une dernière date mais par
contre la rumeur me dis que c'est très
bientôt d'ici deux mois
la suite de ce journal c'est à présent
avec cette nouvelle séquence que vous
avez découvert la semaine dernière
durant le mois de janvier nous vous
proposons chaque vendredi en partenariat
avec l association
betabondieu production à un reportage
accessibles aux sourds et aux
malentendants
l'association à qui oeuvre notamment la
lutte contre les discriminations et la
défense de l'égalité citoyenne entre
sourds et entendants
le reportage à suivre est signée simon
oliel il est consacré à la compagnie de
tir à l'arc de lui en cours qui
préparent la fête de la saint sébastien
à leur saint patron
la compagnie des archers basé à
guyancourt compte une centaine
d'adhérents hilali compétition loisirs
et traditions tant que président moyer
une phrase que j'aime bien reprendre
c'est que chacun des adhérents doit
trouver ce qu'il vient chercher au sein
de la compagnie donc vous avez des
compétiteurs qui viennent eux pour
l'aspect compétition donc s'ils viennent
chercher c'est de l'entraînement et des
conditions de s'entraîner pour pouvoir
faire des compétitions derrière vous
avez des gens qui sont débutants ça
c'est une autre catégorie d'adhérents
donc ils viennent chercher de des cours
d'initiation
vous avez des gens qui viennent aussi
sur elle pour le loisir
la compétition ça les intéresse pas ils
sont plus débutants ils viennent pour le
loisir ils viennent pour le côté
associatif rencontrer du monde tirait
quelques flèches et en fait chacun doit
y trouver sa part c'est un sport qui qui
surtout ciblé vers la concentration
donc c'est vraiment pas qu'un sport
réservé comme les garçons comme
peut-être les sports de combat mais
franchement il peut ça aide aussi les
les plus jeunes à avoir une bonne
concentration à pouvoir progresser en
fait à l'école puisque et ça aide c'est
vainqueur jeudi à la concentration donc
c'est beaucoup plus simple chaque année
à partir du 20 janvier les compagnies de
tir à l'arc de france et de navarre
rendent hommage à saint sébastien le
grand patron des archers de l'an 230 le
club de guyancourt se réunit en
l'honneur de celui qui fut un grand
marché il ya lieu c'était ce week-end
est en fête
my est d'abord un jeu puis après il ya
une carte à lui marqué ses bas sur
sébastien avec l'année et à cesser la
flèche la plus près du centre qui gagne
et apprendre à eschert pendant un an et
on doit faire un blazer pour l'année
d'affaires c'est un moment de
rassemblement de la compagnie est en
fait on note en honneur le patron des
archers et le tir à l'arc en général
c'est quand même un sport qui est très
porté sur la d re tradition beaucoup de
devises dans les archers la devise de
chercher c'est quand même honneur et
loyauté je pense que de temps en temps
dans beaucoup de dents tout le monde que
l'on vit actuellement ferait pas mal de
réfléchir se tue sur ce type de devises
et après le tir à l'arc on reste dans le
sport découvrez à présent le horse ball
c'est un sport équestre collectif lancée
dès 1930 en france le club hippique et
de villevayre à jouy en josas propose
cette activité sujet toujours
accessibles aux sourds et aux
malentendants est toujours réalisé par
simon oliel horse ball c'est un sport
tout nouveau collectif qui joue à cheval
qui est un mélange avec le rugby et le
basket
en fait on a quatre joueurs contre
quatre joueurs et il ya différentes
règles qui sont là pour encadrer la
sécurité et pour dynamiser le jeu
la difficulté de ce sport en fait c'est
qu'il faut mêler l'équitation classique
avec le ballon parce que quand on monte
encore invitation de la normale en queue
du cheval ce que tu sois là il faut
savoir mener le cheval regarder les
autres parce qu'on évolue dans un
univers en 3d avec d'autres personnes
qui évoluent c'est pas vraiment un sport
individuel si je vous disais que c'était
vraiment un sport collectif et du coup
il faut savoir a assigné la capacité à
gérer le cheval son excitation son
équilibre plus le ballon l'entraînement
c'est l'entraînement le plus compliqué
le chan à la synchronisation est le
cheval c'est à dire parfois le fun ne
fait pas du tout ce qu'ils ont envie
bavarois a parfois le cheval est pas
forcément adapté à tout ce qu'on
souhaite c'est pas forcément le fessier
et comment toi tu tu arrives à dompter
ton cheval
j'arrive à tous d'en bas avec le temps
surtout le temps et qu'on prend le temps
de les comprendre
c'est ce qu'il nous est vieux plus on
doit tuer joue toujours avec le même
cheval
il est toujours j'ai changé il ya un an
des as nous change des troupeaux
prochain sujet avec l'association
betabondieu production à découvrir
vendredi prochain dans ce journal une
nouvelle fois pour refermer cette
édition je vous propose à présent de
découvrir ou redécouvrir cette interview
de michel tourat et tournier l'écrivain
pardon c'était 1 dans les yvelines dans
son presbytère de choisel où il résidait
et depuis bientôt 60 ans et nous avait
ouvert ses portes en 2001 écouter
oh
alors vous entendez midi et vous allez
entendre l'angélus de midi
je suis c'est un teint tina bull mans
mais j'ai tourné bonjour bonjour alors
expliquez-moi un petit peu où on se
trouvait ce qu'on l'a on est vraiment
chez vous a choisi un harnais chez moi
parce que j'habite le presbytère de
choisel depuis 45 ans et j'ai écrit tout
ce que j'ai publié et c'est devenu une
partie de moi-même cette maison je vais
vous dire une chose qui est un petit peu
négatif je déteste paris j'ai eu le
malheur d'y naître et j'avais 6 ans
quand mais le médecin a dit à mes
parents si vous voulez qu'ils vivent il
faut quitter paris ils se sont installés
à saint germain en laye et puis je me
suis installé ici joaillier je suis
resté fidèle aux yvelines à l'époque ça
s'appelait la seine et oise et vraiment
je me sens lié effectivement avec 7 e
jeu sud ouest
je fus l'ouest parisien tellement lié
qu'il a même créé un personnage que l'on
retrouve dans ses écrits angélus choisi
luce j'avais tournier c'est un nom qui
est honorable mais enfin qu'il n'y a pas
de quoi faire rêver
c'est un petit peu triviale tournier
alors quand j'ai écrit quand j'ai créé
une pensée sublime
je n'ose pas l'assigner tournier alors
je dis comme l'a dit admirablement le
théologien angélus choisi luche lors de
cet entretien nous avons rencontré un
homme passionné mais surtout comme
enraciné dans sa propriété
un paradoxe intéressant pour un homme de
lettres qui fait voyager les autres par
livres interposés
on se rend compte que vous faites partie
du patrimoine maintenant mais j'espère
enfin pas trop parce que chaque côté un
petit peu funèbre à faire partie d'un
patrimoine yvan provisoire est ce que
vous imaginez qu'un jour votre maison
pour être le lieu d'un inculte d'un
pèlerinage
j'espère que non mais si c'était le cas
je suis pas grave toute façon un
presbytère est une maison très honorable
et je les laissais je n'y ai pas touché
jeu léché tel quel avant de nous quitter
michel tournis en bon conteur qu il n a
pas manqué de nous citer deux anecdotes
sur la vie à choisel deux histoires
ancrées dans la mémoire locale pour
commencer la venue de françois
mitterrand alors président de la
république c'est recommencer avec une
histoire de photo ça et je me suis
toujours intéressé à la photo ayant un
photographe allemand qui a fait un livre
de photographies sur mitterrand et
mitterrand demandé que je fasse la
préface alors je suis allée à l'elysée
pour voir les photos avec le président
et avec le photographe qui s'appelle
conrad muller et en partant mitterrand
m'a dit j'ai entendu dire que vous
habitiez un presbytère dans la vallée
sauvage a dit oui monsieur le président
il me dit si vous vous invitez je viens
je vous invite monsieur le président ce
que vous vouliez que je dise ça se
passait au mois de mai et il a débarqué
au mois d'août en hélicoptère et il a
recommencé l'année suivante il a
recommencé l'année d'après ils ont venu
trois fois
alors quand je suis arrivé ici la grande
dame du village était une grille de
berkman donc le buste est actuellement
dans la mairie son mari la smit et
habite toujours là et alors c'était
assez drôle elle m'invitait deux ou
trois fois chez elle et c'était une
femme admirable de gentillesse et
d'intelligence et elle faisait des
réceptions la nuit et en hiver bien les
invités se perdait alors elle m'avait
demandé la permission de mettre sur mon
garage un projecteur qui éclairait le
clocher de l'église est elle à lui mais
ça les soirs
où elle avait des réceptions et
quelquefois on venait signer chez moi je
reconnaissais des vedettes de l'écran
américain ou français
vous pouvez quand même montré l'église
parce que même à contre-jour c'est pas
si mal que ça
les obsèques de l'écrivain qui se
dérouleront donc lundi à 15h à choisel
tout près du presbytère nous y
reviendrons bien évidemment dans un
prochain journal et nous refermons cette
édition du 22 janvier ainsi merci de
l'avoir suivi très bon week-end sur
notre antenne